[Applaudissements]
il se prend pour dieu annabelle
marionnettes tu vas voir
[Applaudissements]
c'est en fait tu vous présente ses jt
c'est jean tarek chami trois mois
qu'est ce que la main sur puma on
n'aurait pas une fête sur la tête à
donation mais le h
le hall à nc quoi joue t rès interne à
la fin tu fermes ta gueule matin quand
un viatique à la maison tu te fais me
dans la baguette
[Applaudissements]
soit au niveau du lait bio au niveau des
lèvres ya du boulot mais les textes sont
bien les gens paraissent maintenant tu
vas nous laisser d'accord oui ça lui est
rendu là bas c'est un pote que j'ai
trouvé en fait qu'ils étaient avec moi
pendant les vacances